oh
come on
everything is falling apart hey guys
this is inca welcome back to another
episode of trendy vs traditional where i
will be making trendy interpretations of
your favorite classics and today to
represent the traditional side of things
is my really good friend hal
hi hal hi we gotta fix this my tall
friend hal what are we making today
today we are making
pie
[Applause]
what kind of pie do you like best i
really like fruit pies peach pie cherry
pie and apple pie i love apple pie me
too i think it's my favorite i'm making
a lemon meringue pie but like not the
lemon meringue pie you're thinking okay
it's gonna be okay i'm scared
i'm gonna go first today so wish me luck
good luck okay thank you
i think i'm gonna beat you
oh okay
all right well on that note let's get
cooking
i said i was making a lemon meringue pie
but what makes it trendy is that i'm
gonna be making a clear lemon meringue
pie and i know it sounds really weird
probably is a little bit you probably
have heard of the clear pumpkin pie
where there was this clear pie that
tasted exactly like pumpkin pie but
today we're doing lemon meringue pie
because that is my favorite pie i'm
going to be making apple pie i feel like
when you think of a traditional pie
apple pie is kind of the pie that comes
to mind i think maybe the most important
part of a pie of any pie is the crust
has to be really flaky and buttery and
delicious it's also the messiest part so
maybe the most fun i'm using a food
processor this way the butter will melt
in my hands some people like make their
crust in food processors but i've never
done that before so i always just use my
hands we have flour sugar and salt inca
measured out all of my ingredients so if
these are the wrong measurements
sabotage
salt
sugar i'm whisking together all of these
ingredients so they're nice and blended
i have some flour sugar and salt
i'm also adding a little bit of almond
flour to make it even more lemony i am
going to add a little bit of zest i
think that makes things a little more
exciting i really feel like i'm on like
the great british bake off there's three
sticks of butter in this pie crust which
sounds like a lot and it is oh my gosh
there's it's already cubed inca got my
butter see how it's still like super
hard that's what you want putting this
back on and
i'm kind of breaking these up oh the
butter's jumping you don't want to touch
it too much because you want the pie
crust to be flaky now we have a very
very crumbly mixture it's like magic
sand we're gonna start pressing them
together comes together super easily
dope i'm gonna let it chill for around
an hour later i'm gonna take it back out
start folding it over itself to get
beautiful layers they're all friends the
butter and the flour
and the sugar i feel like bob ross now
i'm going to use this little tool you
can cut it
into fourths you can see how there's
butter and flour all kind of in layers
we're just making more of those layers
so you stack them on top of each other
like this and then you squish it down
[Music]
no all right these little dough babies
are done we're gonna put them in the
fridge
while our dough is chilling i'm gonna
start making our lemon custard zest
we're just gonna add a little bit then
now we can juice our lemons when life
gives you lemons you make lemon meringue
ply i have so many apples here granny
smiths honey crisps those are my two
favorite apples i actually have never
used the apple peeler i always just use
like a paring knife cut it down
i am going to add in my juice one whole
egg and some egg yolk add the rest of my
sugar and we're just gonna give it a
little whisk
pour the sugar over top salt brown sugar
cinnamon fresh lemon juice stir these up
get them started while you continue to
cut the apples just waiting for it to
boil
we are finished cutting apples it takes
a pretty long time mental stamina my
arms are tired but we're done and we're
happy about it and it smells really good
and it's gonna make the apple pie
wonderful stir them up and get them all
covered in all that deliciousness we're
going to strain the apples and leave
them chilling here for a second this
process is called
[Music]
macerating oh okay i see bubbles pour
this in here i'm warming up the eggs
slowly but surely and make it into
custard so these apples have been
sitting here for about two hours i'm
just gonna make sure that this is enough
juice
yeah look at that oh my gosh we're right
at half a cup that's a mousing pour this
in here double double
toil in trouble this is going back in
here pretty much just gonna keep cooking
this till it becomes
thick with two seas corn starch and
water slurry this is like kind of
ooblecky maybe i need a little bit more
water yeah this is like looking like
snot one second oh
you want a whisk
yo it smells so good this smells so good
i love that smell it really smells like
a yankee candle look how thick it's
getting strain our little lemon mixture
give a little taste
oh it's very tangy put cling wrap over
this again in the fridge we go this is
the big moment actually no it's not the
big moment but it's it's one of the big
moments i'm going to take the little
jelly stuff and mix it all in look at
that
just get it all in there it's kind of
like making a soup dumpling you can kind
of incorporate it in here i have chilled
my dough for around an hour now we are
gonna do our little folding process do a
little sprinkle on top now i'm gonna
press it down you kind of take out some
anger
now we're gonna fold it in again and
we're just gonna keep on doing this
until there's enough layers going on i'm
just making it into a circle push down
in the center roll it out this way turn
and then i keep pushing all right we're
just gonna roll this out now
and i'm already exhausted come on
oh boy gosh i think we're pretty much
done here so i'm gonna roll this up like
this and roll it over top there we go so
now i'm just shaping the sides i'm just
gonna trim around the edges a little bit
fold it in gently there we go just to
make it a little prettier i'm gonna do a
little bit of crimping and make little
ridges onto the side look at that that's
so satisfying really hoping i'm being
fast enough that looks pretty good to me
honestly so i just leave this on there
and then i put it back in the fridge i
mean it's looking good
that's how hard this pie crust is right
now super super cold putting a piece of
parchment paper aluminum foil i don't
have pilots so i'm going to use some old
beans pop this in the oven bake this
just like this for a couple minutes
after that the pie crust should be done
doing the same thing just another set of
dough and
i'm just gonna put this on the parchment
paper and i'm gonna put this in the
fridge as well it's all about keeping
things cool let's get to making the most
exciting part of this trendy dish which
is
the clear filling we are gonna be using
gelatin it gives you a softer texture
more jiggly texture which is a little
more like custard what we need to do now
is actually let it bloom over here i am
going to add the rest of our stuff lemon
juice some sugars we can add the gelatin
in once it's set we are going to put the
apple filling in the crust now thank god
we are have reached this step apple
mixture into the crust this is gonna
make like that iconic big ol apple path
take your little shears just cut off the
excess does anyone want raw dough
there's no eggs in it
maybe don't do that our gelatin has
bloomed hello everybody
and we are just going to put the little
guy right in here you just want to be
able to dissolve things in there right
now it doesn't smell too pleasant but it
will it will
taste
and it will smell great
i hope these little baby cubes of butter
and we're going to put them on top of
the apple pie now we have to do an egg
wash so go all the way around the crust
and you're working fast it is now one
mixture let it cool a little bit while i
put the custard into the piping bag
here's my lemon curd time to do a little
scoopy scoop and put our hole did you
see that smells like a field of lemons
oh
yeah this is the jam oh yeah it's going
back in the fridge i just pulled the
second crust and this is gonna go on top
so i'm gonna roll this up on the rolling
pin roll it on top and hopefully it fits
look cut off the excess
okay so now we're gonna crimp the pie
oh
i'm so tired here is my pie crust i
added a little bit of egg wash so you
see like the shiny bits with a little
bit of my lemon curd gonna smear that at
the bottom pour this right onto the curd
i filled it quite a bit
i'm scared what i'm gonna do now is very
very carefully put it in the fridge
until the gelatin is
not moving use the egg wash still and
kind of cover it all up some sugar which
is just a reg sug last thing you're
going to do before the pie goes in the
oven is you're going to cut the little
slits in it so your pie doesn't explode
but also to make your pie look cute my
clear pie is here i have my meringue
ready but i'm going to actually pipe the
lemon curd on
we're gonna put the meringue
[Music]
i have a pie we're just gonna go finish
it off give it a little bit of color on
top and then next time we see this it
should be done
all right
i'm finished with my pie i'm gonna put
it in the fridge and then i'm gonna go
preheat the oven
and then it's ready to go
[Music]
it is literally the end of the day
that's why we're on the couch now i can
smell how's pie from over here and your
pie looks
literally amazing can you see through it
i can it's like so amazing before we get
into the pies gotta get judged first oh
god come on sean oh what is this
oops an apple pie smells very good
that's really good the flavors are all
right the textures are great that's
perfect that's all i want it's like a
lemon meringue but the lemon part is
like clear
oh it's like a cool texture
i will say it does kind of taste like
i'm eating jello oh that is really good
though it's a little bit more refreshing
and the flavor is really good i'm into
it
i just need to like get used to it i'm
just gonna have a little bit more hold
on i'm like so nervous i'm sweating
okay so
i think
i'm gonna tie
[Music]
it's really really solid this is just
like something i've never had so it took
me a second i would like go in on that
hey congratulations yay we did it
this is really good ink you gotta say
it's weird but it's so good your crush
is so flaky if i was judge i'd give it
to this that's it guys this is the end
of this season of trending versus
traditional let us know which one you
liked better and also what else you want
to see thank you guys so much
time to eat pie candy pie this one's
mine
[Music]
you